I've never, never seen it do that before.
I normally either shatters or it just about holds, but I've never seen a,
a Holy experiment like this
gonna show you an organic metallic.
So organic metallic just means that there's carbon bonded to a metal on metal.
Today is Allah minium.
And we're going to take the single simplest carbon containing unit,
which is a methyl group, H three. So try me fella.
Minium is actually the world's largest tonnage, organic metallic.
It's quite hard to get accurate numbers, but it's at least 10,000 tons per year.
And you think, Hey, that's a useful compound. It could,
we should be able to do some chemistry with that,
both in the lab and on industrial scale.
But unfortunately the compound has one or two, uh, problems, uh,
associated with it.
And we're going to show you that by attempting to try and weigh out some
trimethyl Ella minium in air.
So I've got a syringe here and we've got it contained within this canister.
I'm wearing gloves for reasons that will become fairly obvious.
So there's going to be a little bit of faffing around here while we get this
opened up in a safe way and thrilling this syringe full of an inert
gas we're using are gone today.
Argon is completely unreactive. I'll just turn that sound off.
So I flushed the syringe three times with argon.
Now that should mean that we can pick up some trimethyl Ella minium with
comparative safety.
So we go down into this canister and I'm just going to take her.
A little bit, and then I'm going to pull this up.
Now, there may be a slight flame as this comes out the end. There it is. Right.
So why can't you weigh out? Try menthol, Ella minium in air. Well,
let's have a look. Here's some in air
and as you can see the compounds spontaneously catching fire as we dump it.
And in fact,
I've put about two grams of trimethyl Allah minium there that's burning with
about the same energy as a one bar electric fire at about the same rate.
And so you've heard the glass crack there.
That's the energy coming out of there. So the trimethyl Ella minium, uh,
has a very weak carbon to alpha minium bond. The bonds,
the alpha minium forms with oxygen are incredibly strong.
So we're getting a massive transfer of methyl to a burnt flame.
And I think if I pick this up,
you can see this is now the severely damaged and that's due to the heat that
was merely generated by turning all of those weak carbon
Alemanian bonds into really strong carbon oxygen bonds.
So you can see a little bit of aluminum oxide left.
That's the same as you would find, I guess,
in a variety of grinding powders or indeed in common
abrasives. It was the extreme heat when we reached about 500 degrees,
C the thermal shock on the ground glass cracked. So, uh,
I don't know about you, uh, viewers today,
whether you'd like to weigh that out in air without special precautions.
Here's the compound, uh, in air, we're just going to release this slowly.
We're going to see a bright yellow flame and oxidation. So going on one,
three, two, one,
okay.
[inaudible] is actually a critical additive in making the
polymerization of the monomers that are bound in our
modern society. So the next time you pick up a plastic shopping bag or a, uh,
uh, a black refuse sack or a piece of plastic Tupperware,
there's a good job that that's come from a catalytic process.
We'll have involved one of the other metals in the periodic table to Tanium,
but that will be completely in, uh,
until we start to mix in some trimethyl Ella minium.
So it's what is known as a co promoter. So if you encounter polypropylene,
you can see that on the back of your recycling thing,
you'll see P P is a good chance that that's come out of an alpha minium promoted
capitalist. You just showed me what to ground. It looks like,
how does industry do with tons and tons of it? Well,
you gotta be pretty careful. And you saw that we had a metal canister here.
It's sealed, it's under all gone. So you need to pipe this liquid around. Uh,
you need to build specialist operators, specialist, plants,
and they can cost many millions of euros or pounds or dollars,
whatever you would like to put together. Uh,
so there's a great lot of this material,
but it's remarkably under utilized in many other chemical applications.
Four three, two one zero
one zero one zero
launch of the first carrier, improved a Ryan to ROA after
you see it on your screen.
So about 10 years ago, we set ourselves the challenge of saying,
can we develop a stabilized version of trimethylamine that's able
to be worked with by, uh, uh, still experienced chemist,
but not without the, the, uh, rather profound danger that we've already seen.
So what we're going to show you now. So an identical watch glass. Yeah.
Here's our compound that we developed, uh, about 10 years ago.
This is now marketed commercially, this tri Meetha Alemanian.
So there's the bit we've already seen.
And then it's got this Diazo by site clue to, to,
to octane Adam. And that sucks so much of a mouthful.
We just call this compound Dabao cause that's much easier to say if you remember
the flames, you should be worried when I'm going to take the top off here.
And I can see a little bit of the fear in your eyes, but if you see here now,
well, it's a whole new ballgame just by making the adduct.
Instead of having a liquid, we've got a white powder,
it's crystalline, it's free flowing.
I'm only going to put a little bit down here,
cause I kind of don't want my watch glass to crack, but as you can see,
even if you are a relatively inexperienced,
so that's much easier to work with now, although this is kinetically stabilized,
it's still got all of the potential power to make those very strong alum,
minium to oxygen bonds for this one, I'm going to give it a little bit of fuel.
So I'm going to cheat by taking a little bit of tissue.
This tissue happens to be blue as opposed to your normal white tissue,
but I'm going to move that out the way.
And so I guess that looks okay about a spoonful.
I'm going to put it on the paper like so, so again,
no major action. Thank you, Darren, for that,
we've need to get just the right amount of water in it to initiate directions.
I'm just putting a few drops.
And what I'm hoping is that that will run through the Hilary. There you go.
So we do get a fire out of it,
but I guess you probably could manage with that fire.
And it's nowhere near the same horrific quantity of energy.
You can see getting very hot in the middle. So I strongly advise you to, uh,
to not do this on the end of your finger,
because it would cause severe burns three, two, one.
Okay.
And I'll be cleaning those line afterwards.
So the black search you can see is actually the, uh,
carbon that's been produced in the flying process.
So we've oxidized up to carbon dioxide,
but we also produced a little bit of graphite that I that's unusual, actually.
I've not noticed that before. So,
but we don't normally spray the stuff around the lab for obvious safety reasons.
[Inaudible] yeah. You just have to clean it up.